hasta ahora nos hemos fijado en las
configuraciones electrónicas para el
potasio y para el calcio pero ahora
vamos a hacerlo vamos a hacerlo de nuevo
realmente rápido porque vamos a ver cómo
esto nos afecta en la forma de pensar en
los orbitales de así que vamos a
encontrar el potasio en la tabla
periódica aquí tenemos el potasio y este
se encuentra en el cuarto periodo de la
tabla periódica verdad y si hacemos la
anotación de gases nobles para
ahorrarnos un poco de tiempo nos vamos
un poco hacia atrás en la tabla
periódica y vemos que el primer gas
noble que encontramos es el argón verdad
encontramos el argón así que escribimos
argón entre corchetes verdad escribimos
argón entre corchetes y sabemos que el
argón tiene 18 electrones tiene 18
electrones y el potasio tiene 19
electrones muy bien así que el potasio
tiene un electrón más que el argón y
ponemos ese electrón extra en un orbital
4s aquí es donde lo colocamos ya que
para el potasio el orbital 4s es de
menor energía que los orbitales 3 de que
tenemos acá 4 veces tiene una menor
energía que los orbitales 3 de verdad y
aquí estamos incrementando en la energía
así que la configuración electrónica
completa para el potasio sería argón 4s
1 perdón argón 4 s 1 para el caso del
calcio tenemos ahora un electrón extra
verdad tenemos 20 electrones y por lo
tanto ese electrón quedaría en este
orbital 4 es verdad y está emparejado
con el espín del caso anterior
así que la configuración electrónica
para el calcio sería nuevamente argón 4
s 2 si ahora nos fijamos por ejemplo en
la configuración para el lyon de calcio
2 más nos fijamos en el guión de calcio
2 más digamos en el caso anterior
estábamos hablando de configuraciones
electrónicas para un átomo neutral
verdad aquí tenemos
un átomo neutral significa que tenemos
el mismo número de protones que de
electrones con y bueno si el calcio
tiene un número atómico de 20 significa
que tenemos 20 protones y 20 electrones
así que si perdemos 2 electrones tenemos
una carga total de 2 positivo verdad así
que formamos el ión de calcio que
tenemos de este lado así que los dos
electrones que perderíamos para formar
el lyon de calcio dos más serían
justamente estos dos por lo que la
configuración electrónica para el calcio
dos más sería exactamente la misma que
para el gas noble del argón que tenemos
aquí verdad simplemente sería cosa de
quitar estos dos electrones muy bien así
que para el potasio una vez que ya hemos
considerado el argón tenemos tenemos un
electrón que considerar mientras que
para el calcio tenemos dos electrones
que considerar verdad aquí está el
electrón del potasio y los dos
electrones para el calcio
y ahora nos vamos al siguiente elemento
en la tabla periódica en este caso sería
el escandio muy bien así que eso sería
un electrón más que un electrón extra
además del que de los que ya teníamos en
el calcio así que tendríamos tres
electrones que preocuparnos después del
argón muy bien hay que preocuparnos por
tres electrones y aquí es en donde
realmente se ponen las cosas muy raras
verdad se ponen muy raras las cosas
porque ahora tenemos que pensar en los
orbitales de iu nuevamente esto se
vuelve muy complicado una vez que
llegamos al scan al es cambio porque las
energías cambian verdad cuando cuando
llegamos al escandio aunque aunque
tenemos tenemos esta diferencia de
energías en esta diferencia en realidad
es muy pequeña y de hecho ahora resulta
que el orbital 4s es de hecho de
energías mayores que el que los
orbitales 3-d así que nuevamente estamos
hablando de un aumento de energía así
que si pensamos en estos tres electrones
en estos tres electrones donde podríamos
ponerlo bueno nuestro nuestro primer
intento seguramente sería digamos si
entendemos estas diferencias de energía
sería utilizando la regla de hong verdad
sería colocar estos electrones con el
espín paralelo
y colocarlos en distintos orbitales 3d
pero eso no es lo que hemos observado
para la configuración electrónica del
escandio de hecho estos dos electrones
estos dos electrones que estoy borrando
este sería el primero y este sería el
segundo estos dos electrones se mueven a
un orbital de energía mayor es decir la
es decir al orbital 4s que tenemos acá
arriba así que la configuración
electrónica resulta ser vamos a
escribirlo con otro color argón 4 s 2
con tres de uno verdad o también de
hecho podríamos haberlo escrito al revés
verdad tres de 14 s 2 y siempre
anteponiendo el gas noble que le
corresponde que en este caso es el argón
así que esto resulta ser bastante raro
cierto y uno podría preguntarse por qué
es que estos dos electrones se movieron
a un orbital de energía mayor y
realmente no hay una explicación fácil
para esto muy bien así que aunque aunque
podría ser más alto en energía para
estos dos electrones no no puede ser más
arte más alto en la energía digamos en
lo en lo global en lo general para el el
átomo completo de el escandio así que
hay muchos otros factores que considerar
así que por ejemplo podría ser un
aumento en la carga nuclear el escandio
tiene un protón extra comparado al
calcio y de ahí que nuevamente tenemos
más factores y de hecho son mucho más
complicados de explicar que que
trascienden el objetivo de este vídeo
así que desafortunadamente no hay una
explicación fácil para este hecho
esto es lo que se ha observado en la
configuración electrónica del skandi y
también podrías preguntarte bueno cómo
es que sabemos que esto es cierto cómo
es que sabemos que este orbital 4s que
estoy que estoy marcando como sabemos
que este orbital 4s de hecho tiene una
mayor energía que los orbitales 3d y en
realidad esto lo sabemos por
experimentos de ionización así que por
ejemplo si formamos el guión de escandio
verdad este guión de scan dio con una
carga positiva entonces la configuración
electrónica para este guión en este caso
estaríamos perdiendo un electrón de un
átomo neutral de escandio verdad así que
resultaría ser resulta ser argón 4 s 13
de 1 muy bien y nuevamente también no es
la única forma de escribirlo podríamos
ponerlo invertido verdad 3 de 14 s 1 y
entonces donde perdimos este electrón
para formar nuestro ion y lo hemos
perdido del
orbital 4 s verdad teníamos 4 s 2
justamente aquí
justamente lo teníamos aquí teníamos 4 s
2 y hemos perdido este último electrón
así que eso tiene sentido para el
orbital 4 s que sea el orbital de mayor
energía verdad porque cuando perdemos un
electrón por ionización lo que perdemos
el select es el electrón que se
encuentra en un nivel más alto de
energía verdad y ese es el más fácil de
remover para formar un guión correcto
así que con esto probamos que el orbital
cuatro veces tiene mayor energía que los
orbitales 3 de verdad y esto no lo verás
muy a menudo en libros de texto yo creo
que la razón principal de esto es porque
si tratamos de pensar cómo escribir las
configuraciones electrónicas en realidad
nuestro objetivo es digamos no sé si a
lo mejor vas a hacer un examen y tu
objetivo es escribir la configuración
electrónica del el escandio la forma más
fácil de hacerlo y vamos a hacerlo con
rojo para esto la forma más fácil de
escribir la configuración electrónica
del escandio sería fijarnos en la tabla
periódica verdad
si estamos utilizando la notación de
gases nobles el gas noble que antecede
al al escandio sería nuevamente el argón
verdad estamos fijándonos en el escandio
y el gas noble que antecede sería el
argón muy bien así que hasta ahora
llevamos la parte que corresponde al
argón verdad y ahora si nos fijamos en
la tabla periódica nosotros podríamos
decir que este es éste corresponde al 4
ese 1 al 4 ese 2 y finalmente al 3 de 1
y eso nos da la configuración
electrónica correcta verdad argón 4 s 2
3 de 1 pero esto implica que los
orbitales de los los orbitales 3 d se
llenan después de los orbitales 4 s y
por lo tanto sería de mayor energía y
eso realmente no es lo que ocurre verdad
así que esto es útil si sólo vas a
escribir la configuración electrónica
verdad pero en realidad no es lo que
está ocurriendo
tenemos que pensar también en los otros
elementos
aquí así que esto fue solo para el
escandio ahora vamos a movernos al
titanio vamos a fijarnos ahora en el
titanio pensemos en el titanio que es
nuestro siguiente elemento en la tabla
periódica y si te preguntan en el examen
que escribas la configuración
electrónica para el titanio la forma más
fácil de hacerlo nuevamente sería pensar
en el argón verdad es escribir argón
entre corchetes muy bien y pensemos para
nosotros mismos que este correspondería
al 44 ese 14 ese 23 de 1 y finalmente 3
de 2 así que podríamos escribir 4 ese 23
de 2 o como siempre hemos estado viendo
estos dos se podrían intercambiar en
realidad da lo mismo muy bien pero
nuevamente esto está implicando que se
llenan los orbitales de después del
orbital 4s lo cual no es cierto verdad
pero al menos te da la respuesta
correcta si fuera
en verdad es muy útil pensarlo de ambas
formas es útil pensar en los niveles de
energía adecuados pero al mismo tiempo
si tu objetivo es obtener la respuesta
la forma más rápida de hacerlo es
fijarnos en la tabla periódica y empezar
a analizar la configuración electrónica
para resolver el examen muy bien así que
fijémonos en otros en otros elementos
que tenemos aquí ya hemos hablado del
escandio y ahora vamos a hablar de él
también hemos hablado del titanio así
que vamos a seguir adelante y de hecho
sería mejor verlo en una nueva tabla muy
bien entonces hasta ahora hemos hablado
ya del escandio por ejemplo hemos
hablado del titanio el escandio por
ejemplo era argón 4 s 2 3 de 1 y ya
hemos hablado de estos electrones verdad
que se encuentran en el orbital 4 s y 1
un electrón en el orbital 3 d y hemos
hecho el titanio verdad el titanio que
es argón 4 s 23 dedos y que de hecho
podríamos haber
intercambiado esto muy bien y cuando
hacemos la notación orbital agregando el
segundo electrón a un orbital de muy
bien es justamente lo que tenemos aquí
verdad este es el que hemos agregado
simplemente hemos seguido la regla de
junto en este caso así que el siguiente
elemento que vamos a considerar es el
vanadio es el vanadio y vamos a hacer
exactamente lo mismo tenemos un electrón
extra que agregamos a un orbital de
verdad pero no lo agregamos en los
orbitales que ya están ocupados sino en
uno nuevo y las cosas se empiezan a
poner un poco complicadas cuando
llegamos al cromo muy bien que vamos a
hacer con otro color digamos con este
color rosa y digamos sí sí sí llevamos
haciéndola la misma regla que llevamos
hasta ahora podrías pensar que sólo
tenemos que agregar un electrón en un
orbital 3d muy bien
pero si hiciéramos esto en realidad
podríamos fijarnos que la configuración
electrónica para el cromo entonces sería
4 s 2 3 de 4 y en realidad hay que poner
una unos signos de interrogación porque
en realidad nos debemos preguntar esto
es lo que realmente ocurre en realidad
no es lo que obtenemos en realidad
obtenemos 4 s 13 de 5 verdad es decir
este electrón que teníamos de este lado
que de hecho lo voy a marcar con rojo
este electrón que teníamos que teníamos
de este lado parece como si hubiera
saltado de este orbital y ocupado este
otro lugar esta esta otra posición que
tenemos acá así que de esta forma es
como obtenemos todos estos orbitales
ocupados verdad así que cuando estamos
escribiendo las configuraciones
orbitales podría simplemente pensar que
este electrón salto hasta este último
hasta esta última posición en los
orbitales 3
algunas personas dicen que el hecho de
que todos estos orbitales detengan un
electrón todos estos orbitales tengan un
electrón le da estabilidad extra al
átomo de cromo pero esto no siempre es
cierto no es la mejor explicación la
explicación real es muy muy complicada y
de hecho sobrepasa todo lo que queremos
describir en este curso de química
general muy bien así que mejor vámonos
con el siguiente elemento que sería el
manganeso y el manganeso tiene un
electrón extra d con respecto a lo que
teníamos en el cromo verdad en el en el
más bien teníamos aquí 6 verdad después
del argón 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5 6 en el
cromo mientras que para el manganeso
tenemos 7 y lo que ocurre en el
manganeso es más o menos lo que
esperaríamos simplemente de recorrer la
tabla periódica así que vamos a hacer
esto para el manganeso vamos a utilizar
un color verde y diríamos bueno este
correspondería al 4
14 s 23 de 13 de 23 de 33 de 43 de 5
verdad que es justamente lo que
obtenemos y de hecho lo mismo ocurre
para el hierro verdad sería 4 s 2 3 de 6
y ahora vamos a emparejar los espines
para el caso anterior que era el
manganeso verdad aquí los tenemos
emparejados y en el caso del hierro
tenemos que emparejar los con este
orbital 3 de muy bien ahora bien el
siguiente elemento que hay que
considerar es el cobalto cobalto que
tenemos aquí y tenemos que preocuparnos
por un electrón extra verdad así que
tendríamos 4 s 2 3 de 7 y de hecho aquí
encontramos ese electrón extra con el
espín digamos con dirección hacia abajo
muy bien ahora nos seguimos con el
níquel con el níquel que tiene la misma
idea que hemos estado llevando verdad
simplemente agregamos otro
tenemos 4 s 2 3 de 8 y aquí se encuentra
el electrón que hemos agregado y luego
continuamos pero nuevamente tenemos una
cosa muy extraña verdad cuando llegamos
al cobre vamos a tachar el cobre y de
hecho mejor voy a utilizar un color rojo
para el cobre muy bien vamos a utilizar
un color rojo y tú podrías pensar que si
partimos de la configuración electrónica
del níquel simplemente al agregar un
electrón tendríamos que agregarlo aquí
con una con el espín orientado hacia
abajo y entonces quedaría como 4 ese 23
de 9 sin embargo vuelve a ocurrir este
electrón que teníamos en el orbital 4 s
4 veces simplemente parece como que se
desplaza hasta el último orbital que
sería el 3 d muy bien y eso nos da a
todos estos orbitales de completamente
llenos verdad completamente llenos para
el caso del
nuevamente es esto es bastante
complicado de explicar pero al menos una
idea intuitiva que algunas personas
utilizan es que dicen que esto le da una
mayor estabilidad al cobre y eso puede
ser cierto para el cobre así que eso
sólo nos deja con un espacio posible
para el orbital 4s así que tendríamos 4
s 13 de 10 muy bien pero todos estas
todas estas explicaciones para química
general son un poquito
son muy simples en realidad
pero digamos que para iniciar son
bastante buenas para digamos irlos
pensando así que finalmente tendremos el
zinc y el zinc simplemente vamos a
agregar un electrón extra verdad ya nos
hemos hecho cargo del del cobre así que
para el zinc tenemos un electrón extra y
podríamos pensar esto simplemente como 4
4 s 2 estos dos primeros serían 4 s 2 y
luego tendríamos 3 de 13 de 23 de 33 de
43 de 53 de 63 de 73 de 83
y 3 de 10 que es justamente lo que
tenemos hasta abajo muy bien y por
supuesto no podemos olvidarnos de
escribir el argón siempre antes de esta
digamos esta parte de la configuración
electrónica muy bien así que como puedes
ver ya hemos llenado el orbital 4s y
también los orbitales 3 de aquí tenemos
lleno el orbital 4 s y los orbitales 3 d
puede ser muy complicado este tema y
espero que al menos con este vídeo
tengas una mejor idea de qué es lo que
está ocurriendo